I am Nicolas be with reason TV and today
we're talking with George Gilder he is a
leading visionary on all things related
to Bitcoin and technology and
telecommunications George thanks for
talking to us well great to be here okay
we're gonna talk about your newest work
the 21st century case for gold a new
information theory of money but first I
want to talk with you about net
neutrality the FCC has gone ahead they
passed their net neutrality rules
they've already started implementing
some of them and finding various
companies are you worried that this is
going to become a big stumbling block to
innovation online or do you think that
will just work around it I think it'll
be reversed I mean I in the courts it's
well you know it's such an egregious
power grab I me imagine title to
transforming the internet into a public
utility neutralizing the internet making
a unit net as I call it's you know
everything everything on the internet is
unneutered
I mean there's you have s always service
level agreements you have content
delivery networks accelerating stuff for
money everywhere you have all sorts of
special channels you have Skype you have
email everything's different everything
needs different treatments when
everything's changing minute by minute
and the idea of establishing a level
playing field as if all bandwidth was
homogeneous is just ludicrous so it's
it's completely based on fantasy so is
it ant really standest so it's it partly
though that net neutrality weirdly
because you know one of the mantras of
the internet is that it was this great
leveling force where suddenly you know
you know NBC or a giant corporation you
know no longer had as much power and
things have been leveled and now in a
weird way because you're right the back
you know behind the internet everything
is everybody has different advantages I
mean is that where it came from where
did the where did the political will and
the public will you know come for
something like net neutrality
it's just the appetite of bureaucracies
to expand their regime and FCC saw the
possibility and the waning years of the
Obama administration to assume power
over the Internet
full of various assurances that they
would forbear they wouldn't do all the
things that a title to Internet based on
1934 railroad regulations would actually
allow them but at the same time they
invite class-action suits and protests
and explicitly mobilize the K Street law
firms and lobbyists to sue which means
that the whole internet will become more
litigious and more perilous for
enterprise and the horizons of the
economy will shrink do you think is the
FCC kind of like the March of Dimes when
polio was cured they they no longer have
a reason to exist and so they're coming
up with a new justice yeah that's right
and they really don't have any reason to
exist they they really the whole idea
that spectrum is like beachfront
property is just nonsense spectrum is
created by technology and it doesn't
exist really without the technologies
that have been invented to use it and so
the whole idea that spectrum is out
there and it's a public resource that
has to be managed by government is
itself delusional so so I think that
they're in a bad situation but the
Internet is on the verge of creating a
layer 8 at last layer I'd explained that
well the internet has seven layers yes
deriving from Claude Shannon and OSI
modeled with the bottom layer the
physical layer of all actual physical
technology than the data link and
network and transport and in session and
presentation and then apps at the top
and but all these layers don't give you
any way to actually conduct
trusted transactions no way to establish
facts no way to timestamp events no way
to produce irreversible contracts and so
we need now a layer eight on the
internet which is bitcoins
it's the Bitcoin block chain should be
layer eight on the Internet
talk about that in the 21st century case
for gold a new information theory of
money essentially you're arguing that
bitcoin is gold yeah bitcoin is gold for
the internet so what what does that mean
well when I started studying gold I was
trying to figure out why gold was such a
fabulous monetary element over the
centuries and a lot of people tell you
that it's because gold is shiny gold as
portable gold as really jewelry and I
was talking to a friend Richard
vigilante and he said no the reason Gold
is valuable is not because it's jewelry
the reason jewelry is valuable is
because it's really money and the reason
it's money is because it cancels out all
the economics of its production the
advance of mining gear the improvement
and exploration equipment all is
canceled out by the fact that gold gets
more difficult to extract the deeper the
loads are the more thin the distribution
and so just by happenstance through
history gold has nullified technology
and economics and become a pure index of
the time it takes to extract it and time
is really the foundation of all
measurement if you go through all the
physical measurements like kilograms and
meters and seconds and lumen
and amperes and moles and whatever all
of them are ultimately based on various
frequencies which are constant of Hertz
in frequencies and ultimately based on
time so you're saying that I don't wait
too much
I just haven't lived long enough okay
time is the foundation of money as a
measuring stick and and satoshi and in
shaping Bitcoin explicitly nullifies
technology he wants to cancel out
Moore's law above all because that would
make Bitcoin merely a function of
advances in the computer industry which
would and you're talking about things
remained creator of Bitcoin that's what
I said I'm we're going to meet her out a
set amount of Bitcoin over time now and
then that would be it that's right and
it's ten minutes per block and that's
rigorously incorporated in the algorithm
that begins with the Genesis block in
2009 and can and then contained in
hashes mathematical fingerprint today in
the latest block so then talk about
Bitcoin as is the gold standard or or it
and for that creates an inescapable gold
standard on the internet now and what
are the implications of that for the
kind of level eight moment well if you
have a level eight transactions layer
that can provide a objective valuation
rooted in the source of all measurement
which is time time is money is really
time time is has to be spent time that
can't be manipulated stolen hoarded it's
distributed equally to rich and poor
it's it's the pure measure the universe
offers and it's the source of all value
and money and that you know we see the
interest is supposedly the
time value of money it's really the
money value of time is what it is and
time is the monetary element and it's
what unifies goals with its happenstance
you'll cancellation of technological
progress with Bitcoin with its explicit
algorithmic cancellation so then talk
about the information theory of money
how is this playing the information
theory was developed by Claude Shannon
in 1948 essentially and it identified
information as unexpected bits as
surprise essentially and and that and
this allowed him to separate the meaning
from the actual flow of information and
and was and he inventing the bitna byte
essentially he made possible the whole
computer age and the Internet Society
but because his measure of information
had no valuation and a no transactional
way or no source of meaning or
measurement the internet kind of fills
up with junk and we have always pop up
ads and and everything is free which
means it's really a lie because nothing
is fully free so so there's the absence
of micro payments has under the existing
information theory regime on the
internet has de blotched the internet
and I believe that the development of
the transactions layer offering seamless
hassle-free transactions across the
internet can allow content producers or
for example to collect their own
payments thus taking the power of
payments away from the aggregators who
aggregate and then advertise and it's
these aren't really ads
my from my point of view there are
minuses you know their value subtracted
advert and that's because they take time
away from that's right a consumer here
let me ask you this so that I mean so
basically what you're saying is blocked
or Bitcoin enables micro payments that
means that you can pay to speed up your
time kind of or like to avoid you know
costs on your time
what is the role and nobody is a bigger
you know ideological capitalists in you
or understands the role of the middleman
the role of the aggregator in this kind
of system because it's not simply that a
major corporation is extracting you know
by its role as an aggregator is acting
as a gatekeeper they also add
information right I mean it's easier for
a record label they go out and they find
all the artists that I might like and
then pitch them to me what it would have
been signs of aggregation and all sorts
of value-added advertising you're
talking about value-added advertising
and marketing processes that actually
deliver what you want when you want it
and Google as a matter of fact is in its
search engine advertising is actually
delivering value-added advertising all
the time and it's YouTube's model
however is deeply value subtracted you
never want to see an ad at the beginning
beginning of your YouTube video so why
is Google is really divided and until it
understands that it has to figure out a
value-added advertising model for
YouTube essentially with the rival of
Bitcoin the content producers on YouTube
will will start launching smaller
aggregators that actually focus on the
markets they seek and don't impair the
experience with some pop-up jerk in the
box or adhesive right well we will leave
it there we've been talking with George
Gilder his latest work is the 21st
century case for gold a new information
theory of money
it's out from the American principles
project George thanks for talking to us
thank you
for reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie